a great pleasure to welcome
chancellor merkel back into the white
house where she's been in the oval
office many times she's been a great
friend
i consider a personal friend as well as
a great friend of the united states and
we saw each other at the g7 and then we
saw each other again
at the nato meeting and uh
and today we're talking about further
advancing strong
u.s german relationships which has been
strong and it's getting stronger
we have a full agenda ahead of us we're
going to be
meeting alone for a while and then we're
going to bring in
some of our key staff and
one of the things that i want to talk
about is the
enduring friendship that the
chancellor's been so responsible for
nailing down and making sure it
continues
and we're ready to dive in
the cooperation between the united
states and germany has been strong
and we hope to continue that and i'm
confident we will
yeah thank you for president
obama foreign
well thank you mr president thank you
very much for the invitation i'm
delighted
to be here we met that is true at the
g7 also at the nato meeting and now we
have an opportunity to talk
more about our bilateral relationship
about relationship between
germany and and america obviously always
in the context of european
uh matters we can also talk about and
address
matters that relate to uh immediate
neighbors geopolitical
issues that's going to be on our agenda
i'd like to say here that
how much i value the friendship with the
united states of america
i'm more than aware of the contribution
of america to
a free and democratic germany so i'm
very much looking forward to
a deepening of our relations yet again
through our talks today and i think we
can
we will be able to elaborate more on
that as we go
thank you thank you all mr president
we're gonna have plenty of time to
answer your questions in a few moments
thank you guys
thank you let's go thank you thank you
thank you so much let's go thank you
thank you
[Music]
you